Brazil has declared three days of
mourning after a plane crash that killed
members of a beloved soccer team their
charter flight crash late Monday while
traveling through bad weather in
Colombia 71 people died in this crash
the team was in the midst of a magical
season you could say they were heading
to the finals of the South American Cup
Josh Elliot of our streaming network
cbsn shows us how the tragedy devastated
Brazil Josh good morning good morning
Gail the Shoppach wins a soccer team was
supposed to play tonight in what would
have been the biggest match in its
history team officials had hoped it
would end in victory and so lead to a
massive celebration instead today they
are planning a mass funeral for
Brazilian soccer Cinderella team there
is no happy ending their fairytale
season over after their charter plane
went down in the Andes Mountains six
people survived the Monday night crash
including three players Alan Raquel Elio
Neto and goalie Jackson foeman whose
right leg had to be amputated his father
told The Associated Press we have not
spoken to him or received any other
information regarding how serious his
condition is that is making us feel
anguished to lose all of them in such a
tragic way totally destroyed the city
and each one of us this fan says this is
video of the team taken aboard their
flight BAE 146 operated by the charter
company Lamia
from Aslan command teams athletic
director said prior to takeoff they had
previously worked with Lamia and were
treated well the Charter was flying from
Bolivia to their match in Colombia a
nearly nineteen hundred mile trip close
to the limit of the planes range
authorities have now recovered the black
boxes at the accident site outside
marine there were reports the plane may
have suffered electrical failure or run
out of fuel this man the father of a
team member who was not on the flight
said it's a disaster there are no words
to explain it the shop ace as they were
affectionately known played in obscurity
for decades
but in 2014 they were promoted to
Brazil's top soccer division and there
were no big stars but with each match
the underdogs following grew just last
week the shop a celebrated their
unlikely berth in the finals of the
second most important club tournament on
the continent South America not just
Brazil but all of South America is
morning and just grieving this it's a
story that doesn't come along that often
and to have it end the way that it did
is really just horrific Elease add their
opponent said the shop age should now be
named South American Cup champions and
in a gesture of solidarity other
Brazilian teams have now offered to help
them rebuild their team by loaning out
their own players and while the global
soccer community mourned last night Pope
Francis also sent his condolences to all
those who are mourning this tragedy Nora
oh it's just horrible to hear your
details all of that just terrible Thank
You Josh